[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we
turned to a viral article in the orlando
sentinel the piece is written by guest
contributor jonathan
van boskirk with the headline i love
disney world but wokeness is ruining the
experience
and it begins this way he says my family
and i have been loyal disney customers
for decades we vacation at disney world
every year we take a disney cruise every
year or two
consequently we spend way too much money
in orlando unfortunately i'm strongly
rethinking our commitment to disney and
thus orlando
the more disney moves away from the
values and vision of walt disney the
less disney world means to me
disney is forgetting that guest
immersion is at the core of its business
model
when i stand in galaxy's edge or fantasy
land
i know i'm in a theme park but through
immersion and my willingness to set the
real world aside something magical
happens
that spell is broken when the immersive
experience is shattered by the real
world
and boy has disney been breaking the
immersion
okay now now already we we have a
problem because
a grown man is describing disney world
as magical
it's arguable whether a grown man ought
to be calling anything magical
unless the thing is literally magical
like if you stumble across a lamp with a
with an actual genie inside it or
something and you could call that
magical but certainly
that sort of sentiment should should not
be applied to a theme park
i've been to plenty of theme parks and
at this point in my life they do not put
me
under any sort of spell if i'm immersed
in anything it's the thought of how much
damned money i'm spending for the
privilege of standing in a series of
long lines while listening to kids
to kids other people's and my own whine
about the line the heat
they want a snack etc etc as i said this
article went viral and most
people are criticizing the writer um
but not for the reason that i'm
criticizing him i take issue with mr
van boskirk primarily because adult men
shouldn't like disney world so much or
at all
and i've made this point before and i've
been told by other adult men
that i'm nothing but a curmudgeon for
saying this because
disney world is the happiest place on
earth and how could i hate the happiest
place on earth
now i am indeed a cumulation but even so
a place that trademarks itself as the
happiest place on earth
and charges you hundreds of dollars to
experience that happiness
is certain to be anything but the
happiest place on earth
for me it's not like i don't have any
happy play for me
the happiest place on earth for me is a
quiet lake
at 6 a.m with a coffee mug and a fishing
rod
second happiest is the same lake 12
hours later with a beer instead of a
coffee
that for me that's the happiest it's
quiet it's free it's peaceful
the idea of trading that in for a theme
park
is repugnant to me on a deep and
visceral
level no way that's my problem with this
article
that's my problem with it everyone else
seems to be taking issue with this part
where he writes quote recently disney
announced that cast members are now
permitted to display tattoos
wear inclusive uniforms and display
inclusive haircuts
disney did all of this in the name of
allowing cast members to express
themselves
the problem is i'm not traveling across
the country and paying thousands of
dollars to watch someone i don't know
express themselves
i'm therefore i am there for the
immersion and the fantasy
not the reality of a stranger's
self-expression i do not begrudge these
people their individuality and i wish
them well in their personal lives
but i don't get to express my
individuality at my place of business
what's next is disney going to end the
rule barring on stage cell phone use by
cast members as an infringement on
self-expression
now people are mocking the writer for
this passage but he's actually 100
correct about this part of it
i personally have no stake in the
uniform requirements for disney
princesses but
as a neutral third party i can say yes
this is stupid
i i if your job is to pretend to be the
little mermaid or whoever
then that's your job nobody cares about
your self-expression nobody goes to
disney and pays all that money to see
you know
sarah johnson from lakeland florida
express herself
they're not going for that they they
want to see the little mermaid that's
why they're there
why they go to see the little mermaid is
a different question why grown men go to
see the little mermaid is definitely a
whole separate question but
that's what they're doing that's what
they want and your job is to give them
what they want it'd be like if i worked
at mcdonald's and i decided that
i was going to personally change the
recipe of the big mac in order to
express myself
if i said you know i i just i'm giving
out these big macs all day and i just
can't i can't communicate my inner
feelings
through this big mac recipe i'm gonna
change it
see the problem is the people in the
drive through line they're not there to
get
matt walsh's twist on the big mac
they're there for the big mac
the same big mac they've always had and
my job is to give them that
again there's the same question as to
why anyone would want that product but
if you work there it's not your place to
be asking those questions
it is not to reason why it is but to do
and die
that wisdom from the charge of the light
brigade applies both to military units
and disney world
employees in my mind so on this point i
agree with mr
uh van boskirk he continues
more broadly like many corporations
disney has been politicizing its
business
disney is in the process of taking the
woke scalpel to the jungle cruise
trader sam is out because he might
offend certain people
every grown-up in the room realizes that
traitor sam is not a representation of
reality
and is meant as a funny and silly
caricature it's no more based in racism
than every disney character of an
out-of-touch white american dad
side note no grown-ups don't know who
trader sam is that's that's the grown-up
perspective on this but anyway
uh the next time i ride jungle cruise i
will not be thinking about the
gloriously entertaining puns of the
skippers i will be thinking about
disney's political
agenda that's a mood killer disney
proclaims that splash mountain must
change because it's
because of its association with song of
the south
disney owns splash mountain so it can do
what it wants
but if disney screams at the top of its
corporate voice which is pretty loud
that it's changing it to appease a
certain political point of view now
every time i look at that ride i'm
thinking about politics
the same with pirates of the caribbean
disney has made significant changes to
pirates of the caribbean over the years
whether disney caved to political
pressure or really thought the
alterations were necessary is irrelevant
finally it concludes with this disney
world is going to lose us as customers
if it continues down this path
i don't want to have disney world taken
away from us because disney cares more
about politics than happy guests
disney please return to the values and
vision of walt
the customer experience should be the
core of your business model immersion
should not be sacrificed on the altar of
political correctness
and appeasing the twitter mob okay
now i join in uh in i joined the writer
in opposing the wokification and
pcification of pop culture i agree with
the general sentiment
though again you wouldn't have this
problem if you were out on the lake
like a man but this man and uh
every other conservative needs to
understand something
disney like so many other companies
hates your guts that is not going to
change
disney hates you despises you
it will gladly take your money if you
insist on pushing your money into its
hand
if you continue to empty your wallet
right into disney's grubby paws
it'll be happy to oblige they'll put
their hands out and sure go ahead give
me all your money
but it hates you and giving disney your
money begrudgingly
scowling and complaining while you do it
that doesn't accomplish anything
money is money you don't achieve
anything by saying gosh darn it disney
i'm not happy with you i'm i'm really
miffed about this oh how much was that
646
okay here you go anyway i am so
displeased with you disney that message
just lacks a certain
uh weight i guess the only thing that
will make a difference
make a dent is if you withhold your
money completely
again disney hates the majority of its
customers
if all of those customers said okay
we'll screw you to then
and took their money elsewhere things
would change
but if you aren't willing to do that
then there's no point in complaining
so we have to make a decision okay
it's decision time either we can shut up
and be good in cooperative little
consumers and open our mouths
and uh and consume whatever they serve
to us
whatever whatever heaping pile of toxic
sludge
they put in front of our faces we could
just dive right in
or we can be discerning and intentional
in how we spend our money
no those are the choices if we choose
the former then we might as well stop
whining and go with the flow
whichever the case it's time to choose
door one or door two
the writer of this article seems to want
to have it both ways and so he is
canceled
also a lot of his critics are cancelled
for disagreeing with his correct points
you know they disagreed with him for the
wrong reasons and so their cancer
and disney is canceled too and the
disney princesses with tattoos
also canceled everyone is canceled
as it should be listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated